come everybody to Long crime daily I'm
Jesse Weber we are one month into a mass
murder investigation in the small
community of Moscow Idaho and we don't
have a lot more answers than we did just
four weeks ago and because of that some
parents are calling the police cowards
Stephen Gonzalez has spoken out
repeatedly about his daughter Kaylee who
was killed along with her best friend
Madison Mogan roommate zonner kernodle
and zana's boyfriend Ethan Chapin the
stabbings happened November 13th as the
people inside the three-story home were
sleeping gonsalves told Fox News that
after speaking with the coroner he now
knows the victims had big open gouges
that were clearly the work of a quote
sadistic male the father had previously
said that according to the coroner and
the death certificate his daughter
Kaylee's wounds were more vicious than
the others indicating that she may have
been the suspect's main target but so
far police haven't said which if any of
the roommates were targeted nor had they
identified a suspect or a murder weapon
forensic death investigator Joseph Scott
Morgan took issue with some of the
information that's coming from Mr
Gonzalez
how does he assess
that these injuries are different did he
see this other victim's body was he the
one drawing this conclusion I doubt that
that's the case so is he saying that the
coroner sat there and said your child's
injuries are so much more worse than any
other victim that's what I have a real
problem with here first off I don't know
how accurate that is and secondly in I
think bigger it's very disrespectful to
these other victims very disrespectful
to these victims and their families to
say this
um right now we we don't know what the
status of the injuries are it's been
very non-specific relative to defensive
injuries who sustained the defensive
injuries with the location of the
so-called defensive injuries are that
sort of thing so
you know right now we're just kind of
getting snatches from him and I don't I
don't know the Genesis of the
information he is he is relating
a former Moscow police captain spoke
with the DeMent Daily Mail defending his
old department and their investigation
Paul kwikowski said quote why they were
targeted nobody knows yet that involves
deciphering all the Digital Data and
they're going to have to go through but
you have 20 people looking at tens of
thousands of pieces of information that
will lead them to something but it's
going to take time if it was my daughter
yeah I'd want to know right now but this
is a tough case the Moscow police are
doing their best their best work right
now kwakowski retired in 2018. now there
is certainly a lot of ground to cover
when any little suggestion could mean a
breakthrough in the case and in their
latest update Moscow police said that
they are pouring over thousands of Clues
over the weekend investigators have
sorted through and prioritized numerous
tips some are tips that came in earlier
and we've been working on other tips are
new and are relevant it's it's
overwhelming sometimes with the amount
of information that comes in on these
tip lines so our analysts have spent
hours sorting through and trying to come
up with the most relevant tips first for
the investigators to follow up on
coast and public defender Brian
buckmeyer as well as co-host and former
trial Attorney Terry Austin join me now
it's good to see both Brian will start
with you you think this could be a
Revenge killing I mean should the
investigation focus on that angle right
now so I got to take it as two parts I
don't know if I'm gonna say Revenge but
I will say a crime of passion Revenge
being a more specific type of passion
when you look at and think and hear the
about these injuries it doesn't sound
like someone who is
um disconnected from The Killing based
on the aggressiveness and the size of
the injuries that are being described
now it's a bit of broken telephone we're
not getting it directly from the corner
we're getting it from the corner to the
father who is then very distressed
understanding so and then convenient to
us so I'm not sure how much credit to
give to it but in terms of focusing on
it only no I think that's going to limit
the investigation there are multiple
Avenues check them all so Terry uh look
we've seen some of the parents of the
victim speak out against law enforcement
it's understandable what what rights do
these families have exactly you know
they actually have a lot of Rights in
Idaho Most states have the this Bill of
Rights in their constitution and in
Idaho they have to be treated with
respect and dignity they have to have a
timely disposition of the case and they
can communicate with the prosecution and
if I'm looking at that I'm interpreting
it this way they have a right to push
the investigators to make sure they're
doing their job and that means
criticizing if necessary I also think
that the prosecution under these
circumstances should be giving more
information and more importantly
accurate information and that's not
happening right here so I do think some
of their rights in a way have been
violated they're not getting what they
need and it's like I said it's
understandable it's a tough case it's a
sensitive case and a lot of feelings and
emotions and opinions are going to come
out as this case progresses well we have
new information for you in a different
case over two years after Brianna
Taylor's death her boyfriend has reached
a settlement with the city of Louisville
Kentucky three officers had responded to
Taylor's apartment during a no knock
search warrant looking for her
ex-boyfriend want a drug dealer Jamarcus
Glover as Taylor's door was knocked down
with a battering ram Kenneth Walker
fired a single shot from a handgun
striking an officer in the leg and that
prompted the officers to return fire
shoot into Taylor's apartment and
eventually kill her now Walker was
charged with attempted murder of a
police officer but those charges were
later dropped as the case got more
attention Walker received two million
dollars from the city and he plans on
using the money to set up a scholarship
fund for civil rights law students along
with funding a police and Community
reform Center
well we're still awaiting verdict in Los
Angeles as deliberations resume in the
sex assault trial of Harvey Weinstein
not a Peep has left the Jury Room since
they got the case eight days ago and
disgraced Hollywood Mogul awaits his
fate behind bars that fate could be life
in prison if he's convicted on on the
seven sexual assault charges that he
faces including two counts of forcible
rape the charges originally stemmed from
four women all of whom have testified
for the prosecution I should tell you
four other women took the stand with
very similar accusations Weinstein did
not testify in his own defense but his
team claims that the accusers fabricated
their stories Weinstein is already
serving 23 years in prison for his 2020
conviction in New York on similar
charges A-list celebrities gunfire or
possibly spurn lover and a bitter Court
battle the California case against Tory
Lanez accused of assaulting fellow
rapper Megan the stallion seems to have
it all now Megan arrived at the
courthouse Tuesday Morning surrounded by
a mob of reporter cameras aren't allowed
inside the courtroom but as you see
people gathered outside showing their
support the rap Superstar said Superstar
says she got into an argument with Tory
Lanez after a party at Kylie Jenner's
house in 2020 when he shot at the ground
not either bullets or possibly shrapnel
were embedded in her foot but she
initially told police that she had just
stepped on glass Lanes is now on trial
for assault and gun possession but he's
maintaining his innocence claiming it
was actually Megan and her former best
friend Kelsey Harris who were fighting
long crime senior reporter Megan cuniff
is embedded for us inside that courtroom
they had body camera footage of the
Police pulling the car over at gunpoint
and then they had the phone call that
Tori made to Kelsey Harris from jail
where he's apologizing he doesn't
actually say what he's apologizing for
but he repeatedly says that he was just
so drunk and that this never would have
happened if he if he hadn't been so
drunk and then they also have text
messages that uh he sent Megan hours
later after he got out of jail saying
you know Meg I'm sorry but again he
doesn't actually say what he's sorry for
in there so uh Tori's lawyer is was able
to say that he he wasn't apologizing for
the shooting he was apologizing for
causing the situation that led to the
shooting which is some kind of love
triangle jealousy thing between the two
women Tori's lawyer says
Brian it may sound like it's all just
you know Petty drama between rich people
but Tory Lanez is facing some serious
assault charges here that's right Jesse
he is facing a little under 23 years and
possibly deportation now Megan this
dallian took the stand on day two where
reporters say that her voice cracked at
the first question and when she was
asked do you know Daystar or Peterson
and she said that she was nervous
reportedly because she just doesn't feel
good and she said I can't believe I have
to come up here and do this in some ways
throughout her testimony she
contradicted to the defense's theory and
laid out uh that they that they had laid
on their opening but also contradict to
the prosecution's theory as well we
heard about her relationship with Kelsey
Harris that she denies being jealous of
lanes and asked to leave with him and
his security guard because that was her
ride she said that Lanes got angry with
her I had nothing to do with jealousy
had everything to do with her Comfort
level at that time and she said that she
lied to the police because she was
afraid she's going to be on the stand a
little bit more but I I expect your
cross-examination to be very lengthy
yeah Terry we're kind of in the
beginning stages of this but based on
the evidence so far what do you think
the end result is going to be when all
said's done yeah I do think there's
going to be a conviction against Lanes I
don't know exactly which charge is going
to stick but something is going to stick
look there were four people in that car
and we know that Kelsey is going to get
on the stand at some point and she's
probably going to say look I didn't do
the shooting The Bodyguard didn't do the
shooting and we know that Megan the
stallion didn't shoot herself in the
foot so I do think that he will get a
conviction at one point and absolutely
she's going to be supported by the
witnesses so far we've heard from a
couple of police officers at least one
who has said that what he was told at
the time of the incident supports what
Megan the stallion is saying so I think
at the end of the day the jury is going
to say look there's enough evidence here
to convict see I think this is a
fascinating case because you got bad
facts for the defense and bad facts for
the prosecution this is a classic case
where I mean I really don't know which
way it's going to go but we'll continue
to follow it